la pluie tombe enfin sur le sud du berry
des millimètres d'eau qui ont bien
manquer dans ce deuxième semestre 2010 8
le préfet de l'indre a décidé de lancer
début novembre la procédure de
reconnaissance de calamité agricole pour
les fourrages
les éleveurs cherchent donc du foin tout
azimut pour leurs animaux guillaume
conscience vient d'en trouver 30 tonnes
à peine quinze jours d'alimentation pour
sont ces deux fois que j'ai trouvé une
petite avance une petite annonce du bon
coin exactement c'est c'est ce qu'on
m'avait conseillé de faire j'y croyais
pas trop et en fait c'est sur le bon
coin que j'ai trouvé du fonds ont
racheté mais comme d'habitude quand la
demande est forte
les prix augmentent aujourd'hui moi j'ai
deux réussi à trouver du foin à pas cher
ce qui est exceptionnel parce que là
j'ai donc le camion de jeunes rentrée
c'est du foin qui est à 90 euros la
tonne mais on n'en trouve pas très très
peu voire pas du tout aujourd'hui les
tarifs
c'est pratiquement du 130 euros minimum
et on voit des annonces à 230 euros la
tonne il faut sortir de la trésorerie et
la santé de l'exploitation de guillaume
ne le permet pas il s'est installé
seulement 2016 l'instruction calamités
agricoles risquent de durer a minima six
mois il se retourne donc dans la région
centre l'état de calamité agricole a été
déclenchée le dossier va partir à la
commission nationale
il n'est pas sûr que qu'il soit accepté
et même s'il est accepté ce ce ne sera
pas suffisant ça ne concernera pas tous
les éleveurs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est insuffisant c'est la
raison pour laquelle on m'a sollicité
l'aide du conseil régional pour aider
les agriculteurs de la région centre
onur demande qu'il y ait un fonds
financier pérenne
qu'ils soient là chaque année pour
permettre d'aider les agriculteurs à
faire face aux aléas climatiques
quel qu'il soit en attendant l'état et
la région les agriculteurs ont de plus
en plus de mal à trouver du foin et de
la paille pour leur cheptel
un hiver 2018 qui risque d'être bien
long pour eux